WILL.
TELL EVERYBODY THERE OUR HEART
REALLY DOES GO OUT TO THEM.
AS THE STORM RAVAGED FLORIDA
LAST NIGHT, OVER IN BOW NEAT TO
BONITASPRINGS NEARLY DROWNED, BE
WAS RESCUED BY A GROUP OF
COWBOYS.
>> JACOB!
>> Jesse: LENNY AND THE REST OF
COLLIER COUNTY COWBOYS RESCUED
THE MAN IN HIS CAR IN BONITA
BEACH.
JOINS US NOW.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, COWBOYS.
THAT WAS A BIG RESCUE.
EVERYBODY REALLY APPRECIATES
THAT.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE OUT THERE?
>> PRETTY BAD.
CAN YOU HEAR ME?
>> Jesse: YEAH.
I GOT YOU.
>> YEAH.
IT WAS PRETTY BAD.
WE WANTED TO GET TO THE BEACH.
WE NOTICED THAT, AND WANTED TO
MAKE SURE EVERYONE WAS SAFE.
THE SURGE CAME IN REALLY QUICK.
WE STARTED MAKING OUR WAY BACK.
AS WE WERE COMING BACK, IT WAS
STARTING TO GET 3, 4, 5 FEET OF
WATER IN SOME AREAS.
IT GOT ROUGH PRETTY QUICK.
>> Jesse: WHAT DID THE WOMAN
TELL YOU WHEN YOU PULLED HER OUT
TO SAFETY?
>> IT WAS A GENTLEMAN.
HE WAS DISTRAUGHT, HAD NO IDEA
WHAT WAS GOING ON.
WE REALLY FELT BAD FOR HIM.
HE TRIED TO GET OUT.
DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH POWER TO GET
OUT IN THE CAR, AND THE WATER AS
PRESSING ON THE CAR.
WE WERE ABLE TO JAM IT OPEN, GET
HIM OUT.
>> Jesse: HOW IS HE DOING RIGHT
NOW?
DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA?
>> NO.
WE HAVEN'T TOUCHED BASE WITH HIM
SINCE.
WE TOOK HIM TO SAFETY.
ANOTHER GENTLEMAN CAME NEXT TO
US.
HE SAID HE HAD A HOUSE ABOUT A
MILE BACK.
TOOK HIM TO HIS HOUSE, AND SAID
THAT HE'LL TAKE HIM BACK HOME.
WE WEREN'T ABLE TO STAY IN TOUCH
WITH HIM JUST YET, BUT WE WILL.
>> Jesse: HE OWES YOU GUYS A FEW
DRINKS.
HE OWES YOU BIG TIME.
NOT THAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
ANYTHING, BUT HE OWES YOU BIG
TIME.
YOU PULLED OFF THIS RESCUE, AND
NO ONE LOST A HAT, IT LOOKS
LIKE.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
THESE ARE GOOD HATS.
>> Jesse: GOD BLESS THE COLLIER
COWBOYS.
WE LOVE YOU HERE AT FOX.
"PRIMETIME" LOVES YOU.
THANK GOD YOU WERE THERE WHEN
YOU WERE.
IF IT HAPPENS AGAIN, I HAVE A
FEELING YOU GUYS WILL GET BACK
OUT THERE.
>> WE'LL BE RIGHT THERE.
WE'LL BE RIGHT THERE, READY TO
SAVE, ANYTIME.
ANYTIME, ANY PLACE.
>> Jesse: YOU GU